[موسيقى]
هذه هي قاعة مشاهير
الجولف العالمية في قرية الجولف العالمية في سانت
أوغسطين
، وقد تم تشكيلها للحفاظ على
تاريخ اللعبة
وتكريمه ، وليس من السهل إدخالها إلى قاعة الشهرة
حتى يتم اعتبارها
عليك  لديك ما لا يقل عن 15 فوزًا
في إحدى الجولات المعتمدة عالميًا
أو اثنتين من البطولات الكبرى ،
لذلك بمجرد استيفاء هذه المعايير ،
يمكنك أن تؤخذ في الاعتبار
وبعد ذلك يبدأ هذا النوع من
العملية ، لذلك هناك عملية أولية
هناك مجموعة  نسمي
اللجنة الفرعية للاختيار
الخاصة بنا ، وهم يذهبون إلى جميع المرشحين المؤهلين
ويتوجون باختيارات
من سيتم تجنيدهم في قاعة
الشهرة ، جمال
هذا المكان هو أنه عالمي حقًا ، إنه
ليس متمحورًا حول أمريكا ، إنه ليس
مركزك الأوروبي
الذي نتخذه  لعبة الجولف في
السياق العالمي
وأولئك الذين يتفوقون في الصعود إلى القمة ويتم
التعرف عليهم
عالميًا وهذا هو المكان الذي يحتاجون فيه إلى
أن يكونوا أفضل اللاعبين اليوم.
لقد وضعوا نصب أعينهم للوصول
إلى القاعة عندما يحين الوقت
الذي يعزز مسيرتك المهنية ، فهو محدد
بشكل ملموس ،
فأنت لست مجرد
لاعب هناك تعلم أنه جعل أمواله
تلعب بشكل لائق وأنت تعلم  مسيرة مهنية جيدة
ولكنك تعلم أنه سار في طريقه المبهج الذي
تذكرته بالفعل
لأنك من الأشياء الرائعة التي
قمت بها في ملعب الجولف
ونأمل أن تكون خارج ملعب الجولف أيضًا
بحيث يعزز حقًا أنك تعرف
حياتك المهنية
كصديقة  شخص
بالإضافة إلى قاعة الشهرة ،
يغطي المتحف كل جانب من جوانب اللعبة على
مر السنين ،
وهناك معروضات لا حصر لها حتى
النادي الذي استخدم لضرب كرة الجولف في الفضاء ،
ومن السهل أن تضيع هنا في كل
تاريخ اللعبة
الذي لدينا  المعروضات الهائلة في جميع
أنحاء المتحف هنا نريد التأكد
من مشاركة
ميراث هؤلاء الأعضاء
مع عشاق الجولف في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
لذلك
نحن نركز بشدة أيضًا على نقل هذه
القصص إلى
الأشخاص هناك  معروضات غير عادية هنا
في القاعة ،
حسنًا ، أعتقد أن كل واحد منهم
فريد من نوعه لدرجة أنه غير معتاد ، لا أعرف
أه في خزانة uh jimbo ozaki ، لديه
سيف ساموراي ، لذا قد ترغب في تسمية
ذلك
بأنه غير معتاد بعض الشيء ليس هناك من يقول
ما ستراه هنا
هو رحلة استكشافية على
الرغم من جميع التحسينات التي تمت مناقشتها
في منتدى أعمال الجولف القريب
عندما تتجول في هذا المكان ،
ستدرك قريبًا أن اللعبة تحتاج إلى التطلع
إلى الأمام
ولكن يجب ألا تنسى ماضيها أبدًا